a two hour boat ride off the coast of
Colombia is an island the most densely
populated island on earth
[Music]
santa cruz del is latte consists of more
than 1,200 people living on land the
size of two soccer fields making it four
times as dense as manhattan on the
island is a school that runs up to the
tenth grade two shops and one restaurant
there is no steady supply of water and a
Seoul generator that only runs for five
hours per day there are no police but
there isn't much need for them as
everyone on the island knows each other
a hundred and fifty years ago the island
was primarily uninhabited and was
sometimes used by local fishermen as a
place to rest and take shelter during
storms gradually some fishermen came to
build their homes here these were the
grandparents and great-grandparents of
the current generation of residents
despite the close living quarters
inhabitants on the island say they
wouldn't give up their peaceful
existence for anything not even a little
more room
[Music]
Oh Kenosha Irma Island is a short 12
minute ferry ride from her ocean land
region of Japan while the sandy and pom
line beaches are perfect for
holidaymakers the island draws crowds
for a different reason
rabbits lots of oh and how they got
there is a mystery between 1929 1945 the
Japanese army secretly produced over
6,000 tons of poison gas on Okinawa
Island
some believe the current rabbits are
descendants of those brought to the
island to test the gas but the current
director of the poison gas museum
insists these bunnies have nothing to do
with those from the world war ii era so
where did they come from
you know saggy kimono saggy you don't
necessarily get on this you know more
one theory a cocoon in science
redecoratin ah Thank You Nana zucchini
today
khadijah so apodaca Tita Saki naka de
uno momento de artes money mata mata
deliberately muscle so those rabbits
were released and with no real predators
they bred like well like rabbits and yet
another theory
I'm Ariana Ishikawa is Joey Votto day I
know can coordinate dhakini
who's a youkai hajimeta so today Amano
Okinawa day talk some creative me they
come coca call your karate master so you
do very nicely
either way this new generation of feral
rabbits has a run in the land they're
creating a new story separate from the
sordid past of Okinawa Island an island
once known for death is now known for
possibly the cutest thing ever
bunnies
just over 30 miles away from the
Slovenian capital this alpine lake looks
like it belongs on the cover of a
storybook
[Music]
with a fairytale cliffside castle and
emerald green freshwater lake and views
of some of the highest peaks of the
julian alps Lake Bled and it's Island
Church make a postcard perfect scene
to visit the Assumption of Mary Church
you must catch a ride on a wooden boat
known as a plenty clintus have been
taking visitors to the island in the
middle of the lake for centuries once
reaching the island it's a 99 stone step
climb to reach the entrance to the
church it is said that if a groom can
carry his bride up these steps and ring
the wishing Bell at the top the marriage
would be a happy one
[Music]
the church is most famous for this bow
which was made in the early 16th century
and is said to be a gift from the Pope
legend has it this was the church's
second cow
the first was bought for the church by
an inconsolable Widow in honor of her
late husband who was murdered and then
thrown into the lake
when boatman brought it across to the
church an unexpected storm hidden and
the bell sunk to the bottom
it is said if you listen closely in the
dead of night you can hear the sunken
bell ringing from the depths of this
picturesque elite
[Music]
coastal at one moment isolated island at
another mall semi shell is incredibly
stunning
no matter the tide
[Music]
in between two powerful tides from
Normandy and Brittany stands the Gothic
styled Benedictine abbey named after and
dedicated to the Archangel Saint Michael
Montse michel wasn't always an island in
prehistoric times it stood on dry land
however as sea levels rose erosion
reshaped the coast even today it only
sits 600 metres from land although it
has less than 50 full-time residents
that is visited by more than 3 million
people each year
the climb to see the abbey isn't easy
it's around 900 steps
more than just a church on Iraq malsu
Michel is a medieval time capsule and
was one of the first monuments to be
classed as a UNESCO World Heritage Site
back in 1979 thank you very much
[Music]
I'm Katherine and this is my husband
Wayne I'm Wayne and welcome to freedom
code
[Music]
we live in a secluded Cove the only
options we have to get here is by water
there are no road accesses the water is
our highway everything that you see here
in our home is floating
we are tied to shore with lines we are
not anchored we have our main living
house we have the dance floor the
lighthouse building for green houses as
I started to grow the garden and make it
larger than we had to have more space
for that garden everything is done with
a handsaw on hammer no power tools I
know every board and nail by name it's
about 500 tons a million pounds and I'm
flowing I've been building a tree fort
since I was seven and I said Road dad
and putting the tree fort in the ocean
no when I go uptown again Lansing mm-hmm
the thing about living in clack would
sound on the west coast of Vancouver
Island it's the richest biomass on earth
so the opportunity to fish for dinner is
thick I just need get in my canoe and
paddle out in ten minutes I can catch a
fish but when it's windy in two to rough
out there I'll land the coach or fish
out of the house I was hoping to make a
lot more money as an artist so
subsistence living was our only
opportunity to have anything as artists
we could never buy real estate so we had
to make our own it was a great
opportunity to actually move away from
the city to see if we could prosper out
here now 24 years later we're still
doing it
I can't imagine living any other way I
feel completely fulfilled that's in the
southern part of Croatia in the
peninsula of paljah Zach there is a
winemaker that does things a little
differently I mean by Odin a president
we know is promoter that's right
this winery ages their wine 75 feet
beneath the sea surface after growing up
around many traditional winemakers Edie
had an idea to combine his two favorite
pastimes scuba diving and drinking wine
so he decided to try an aged wine in the
sea well build a star movie no ob9 140
Kotaku polygons a memorial to avoid any
leaks in these ancient storage jars IDI
uses a glass bottle to keep the wine in
and saltwater out he uses custom-made
cages that line the sea floor to hold
the wine in place both estoy bonito war
nadir first chapter also not known a
primadonna respond oh dear no podía God
in any cotton Adira
Albertina chassis Provera Visakhapatnam
stack Donna says Aranya the say we
destroy a cocoon a state
Oberlin
temperatura McCoy Sweden and Germany
semolina eastern a virginal partnership
WT silly party Sheena the Elinor factor
Oscar me Jenny medaka do not appear
conclusion Avena aunty
it's the silence that differentiates his
unique underwater wine from the park
Sat response team Potro Bhima token
godina ceraadi
Madison Medtronic a primitive assassin
era devises an astronomy geometry it is
Lukovic quested Raja Oppo drama silvano
Tetsu
every energy organism booty - na na na
[Music]
we know da ba da gachi pune oak who's
never driven on what's normal Apache
Lana
me llamo was it a Tara's acrostic a
political shoe bottom business was
Papa's not his familiarity signature of
I pre-med the acapella chorus